نتابع معكم من اسطنبول تغطيه الانتخاباتي
في تركيا حاله من الترقب تسود الشارع
التركي مع بدء عمليه فرز الاصوات في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه وتوالي
النتائج الاوليه من الصناديق التي يجري
فرزها تباعا النتائج الاوليه غير الرسميه
تظهر حصول الرئيس اردوغان على نحو 52% من
الاصوات مقابل 42% من الاصوات المنافسه
للجدار اوغلو وذلك بعد فرز نصف الصناديق
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات كان قد اعلن رفع
حظر النشر عن النتائج الاوليه بدءا من
الساعه السادسه والنصف بتوقيت المحلي وقال
ان الانتخابات لم تشهد تسجيل اي خروقات
بالنسبه للرئيس اردوغان فكان قد اتجه الى
انقره من اسطنبول لمتابعه سيد اجراءات
الفرز وقال بعد انتهاء عمليه التصويت ان
الانتخابات جرت على نحو يليق ديمقراطيه
بلاده اما بالنسبه لينافسها الرئيسي
كمايكلجدار اوغلو فيتابع ايضا اجراءات
الفرز من انقره ودعا الى عدم ترك صناديق
الاقتراح حتى فرز اخر الاصوات تابعونا
لمعرفه اخر النتائج
[موسيقى]